do you know how much I'm paying every
single month in these loans I seven
hundred and seven dollars you know how
much of that actually goes into the loan
itself
sixty four sixty four dollars the rest
of that goes into interest six hundred
and forty three dollars goes into
interest like how does that even make
sense how is that even legal loaning
money at interest and that it is one of
the biggest sins and problems in North
America today planned simple it's a sin
and it is cursed by God so if you were a
real country you would make it illegal
period that's it make it illegal to
start a business that loans money to
people at interest done that's what the
Bible says and that's what God wants
don't argue with it just do it usury is
loaning someone money and charging them
interest that's what user is now in our
modern vernacular the word usury has
changed meaning conveniently for those
who practice usury see usury today means
you're charging an excessive interest
rate above twenty nine point nine nine
percent so if you're charging thirty
percent plus that's a crime
that's usury and whatever but that's not
what the Bible it finds is usury Oh No
the Bible defines any any amount of
interest being charged as usury you say
prove it from the Bible
[Music]
[Applause]
and how are you doing I'm doing great
I'm gonna hide in this Ramadan that's
amazing we made it huh we made it it's
only like ten eleven days over it's
crazy dr. utter yes sir
dr. Arthur Huck Huck is coming in all
the way from Dallas Texas Dallas Texas
and warm weather Dallas Texas huh now
tell us is this true I mean when I heard
these staggering numbers 44 million
Americans are nearly 1 these are the
students now are nearly 1.5 not billion
or million but trillion in debt exactly
so actually 1.5 trillion dollars of
student debt it's the second greatest
debt in the u.s. and unfortunately many
many Muslims are also part of these 44
million students that are in debt
subhanAllah it's a it's a very dangerous
number and it's gonna have a really big
impact on our economy soon I mean those
numbers when you when you think about
that you say that I it just it's just
mind-blowing
and now how does that relate to what
we're going to be talking about that you
and ended up trying to make a difference
and you started an organization was it
because of how it was the name of your
organization is a continuous charity so
how does that connect now to to this
debt this problem that we're having yeah
so this student debt crisis it has it's
having a lot of repercussions so it
continuous charity is the first and only
Muslim nonprofit organization that gives
interest-free loans for college
university and grad school so we're not
a bank but a nonprofit organization that
its sole goal is to promote education
amongst the Muslims and to make it River
free or interest-free that's our main
goal
hamed it out we started in June 2013
time that we started with this a small
kick-off kind of fundraiser at my
father's house and we'll get to his
story a little bit later but we were
able to raise $50,000 at that night as
like the seed money for the organization
have another six years later now we've
given over 1.5 million dollars to Muslim
students to help again promote education
and to protect them from going to war
with Allah and his messenger so Ilario
center do you think now the the
consequences you know it's interesting
how these words have changed because
many people they don't they're they're
paying the interest which is usury and
usually people play these games you know
say well in the Quran it says usury I'm
paying interest have you heard these you
know arguments and we've definitely
heard these arguments I feel that people
are now kind of getting to understand
exactly how bad student loans are
because it's now it's not only affecting
non-muslims but affecting their own
children and so they're now seeing there
were percussions on their own chills in
this generation that has now become part
of it as you get higher education yes so
it's definitely is this clip now let's
play this clip do you know how much I'm
paying every single month in these loans
I seven hundred and seven dollars you
know how much of that actually goes into
the loan itself sixty four sixty four
dollars the rest of that goes into
interest six hundred and forty three
dollars goes into interest like how does
that even make sense
how is that even legal it take me 30
years to pay this entire loan off and
even when I do I'm paying triple the
amount so let me get this straight you
can't drink alcohol till you're 21 but
you can get a hundred thousand dollar
loan at eighteen explain that to me
I had no idea what I was signing up for
my parents have never been to college so
they didn't know either
and what's even worse is that they
co-signed on my loans so even if I can't
pay you back you're gonna go after them
are even if I tie you guys are still
gonna come after them instead I can't
even I can't get married yeah can't even
buy a car I can't get him buy a house
I can't do anything to move forward my
life is frozen I feel like I'm in a
prison these loans have taken over my
life I feel like there's just there's
just no way out anymore please
there's gotta be something you guys can
do I mean just just just gotta be away
[Music]
this clip did you guys put this together
where you have this student he's calling
in to have some mercy from the people oh
yeah yeah this is actually a true story
so it's it's a true story and we will we
re-enacted the scene but it's it's a
true story somehow and it's really sad
to see how much how much student debt or
debt in general impact not only your
help but your mental health and this I
think is a really good example tell us
about this story a lot did you know well
so I didn't know the story I didn't know
that but they're personally but we you
know just doing a lot of different
research going to different websites
reading about different people in
different in their debt situations and
this is just one of the stories so this
is just this is an American this is a
regular American American you know
American citizen who going to school in
the Western society and seeing how
difficult it is to come out of any kind
of debt and not only that is impact his
immediate life and just how he feels but
him getting married his parents who are
co-signers on the laws I'm in if affects
not just you but your family your future
wife your children and all the this is
that you make for the future seems like
people you're chasing this dream that's
painted and at any cost you want to get
it and obviously there's nothing wrong
you want to be the best in your field
you want to get an education but at what
expense now and now it's the beauty the
beauty of this dean is that we have
these perimeters you know these
guidelines that we live by and it's for
our protection for our well-being so you
go out of those and now you can see like
from this story this student now okay
yeah he gets to education but he is in
slave he's done I mean he can't like now
it just compounded interest a pump
compounded and then now what turned out
to be what was what would you estimate
something an average student loan is I
mean so right now it really depends up
from graduate school to like just
regular bachelors so you're talking
about beating $28,000 always even forty
or fifty thousand dollars for a
to school and even like if you're
talking about law school medical school
we're talking about a hundred and twenty
eight thousand dollars on average for
these fields to come out of so you're
gonna eventually be in Slig your
settings slave to these deaths that
you're gonna pay over ten or fifteen
twenty years and eventually paying two
or three times its actual amount that
you got out from the bank nurse okay to
simplify so you get a loan for a hundred
thousand at the end now like he said in
the video I'm paying monthly what was he
saying he was paying he was paying like
only it was like ninety percent was
going towards if I just just the
interest exactly and the way these banks
are is they will front-load the interest
so you'll start paying only the interest
and then eventually you'll get to the
principal so it's a really difficult
situation so if you can't pay these
debts off immediately or like I said
having an interest-free debt then you're
not paying almost anything to the
principal amount and you'll see that
numbers stay exactly the same even
though you're paying seven hundred
eighty dollars a month that principal
will say the same unfortunately so now
if you get a loan for a hundred thousand
at the end when you finally if you do
make it to paying it off then what is it
it triples quadruples what is it so it
depends on how how aggressive you are
but generally we'll see at least two to
three times more you'll pay off
unfortunately yeah especially and also
depends on the interest rate you get on
general we're talking between six and
eight percent is what we're seeing now
but in the past interest rates are much
lower but unfortunately with the the
availability of getting loans these
interest rates and the need for getting
it as least the perceived need of
getting a higher education these is
interest rates have definitely climbed
it's interesting when you look when you
go back in time and history you had the
church had forbidden this this was
something that was outlawed you had you
know philosophers were talking about
this even if we don't you don't even you
know bring up the Quran or the Sun but
you had people wise people over the past
they were warning against this and it
was outlawed at one time yeah the
history about this definitely yeah
definitely I mean it's it's amazing how
Islam in general has this ability to
protect us not from our just our
spiritual bodies our health and even
from finance it's a complete way of life
and a lot like you said even if we don't
need to talk about clear and send in
Allah but just in the fact that like
Allah has made this religion complete
and perfect and it takes care of every
single facet of our life and this is
just one of the negatives that people
are now
delving into so much interest that is
that it's now affecting us in a really
awful way so far I can't I can't imagine
because truly when when you live
debt-free you do live a free human being
I mean when they're shackled you know
when this is shackled by something like
this over your head and what happens if
you die now let's say if you die or if
you declare bankruptcy hmm what happens
so that's a really good question so
student loans unfortunately it's such a
such a predator type system I mean any
other debt like your if you go into debt
from with your house your car you can't
declare bankruptcy and they'll just wipe
that away but what student debt it's
unfortunate not like that you can't just
declare bankruptcy and they'll write
wipe wipe or your debt they'll go after
you they'll go after your job they'll go
after your parents I mean to really the
only way you can really get weight of it
is if you die and it's a terrible system
and it's so sad that students are trying
to benefit themselves when I benefit
themselves but their families future
generations and the society but this
society in particular these banks and
the government are taking advantage of
them and these people who are in like
the prime of their life and they're
unable to get out of this debt and if I
said affects like not even just their
health but their decisions they make on
a daily basis it's a really sad
situation follow I mean this is criminal
yeah really yeah I mean it definitely is
just to put it like black and white
straight forward this is this is
criminal and that's why in the verbatim
word of God Almighty Allah the Quran
that's why there's such a harsh you know
language you know condemning this and
and and and really having people putting
fear you know into the the person that's
living by this by the guidance of the
Creator just stay far away from it don't
indulge in it sure so we're giving some
points where like the person in the
video which is linked back to a true
story he was like I was young I didn't
know I didn't you know he's like you
have to be 21 to buy alcohol but you let
me get this hot loan sign my life away
pretty much to be indebted at 18 no
that's crazy
it's great I think one of the things
that our organization it continues
surely does is to provide education for
these students who or maybe they might
be the first person and their family
going to college and their parents are
maybe immigrants and they don't know the
college system the higher education
system in the US
so we try to provide education on which
is the best how is the best way to go to
school interest-free and even if we can
make it that free let's make it that
free even if it's interest-free debt but
but no debt is is better right so we try
to provide education but how to get
scholarships how to apply the FAFSA how
to get Pell grants different things
because at the end of the day you want
to get your education and you want to
start your life you don't want to then
have to go back and be enslaved to your
own your financial decisions you made at
the age of 18 for the next thirty years
of your life you want to kind of move on
and so that's some of the education that
we do with our with our nonprofit a
continuous charity is to help these kids
make the best financial decisions even
though they're you know 18 19 and maybe
don't have the best experience how did
you make it cuz you're you're a medical
doctor yes a profession so you had to go
through this is how did you get to all
this so you know that's a really great
question and soupçon it really goes back
to my father my father at a very young
age was instilling education into us and
I guess it's part of like the Indian
Pakistani culture is you have to be an
engineer or a doctor so he actually grew
up in India in poverty he used to say
they used to study under streetlights so
he had to you know he had a really
difficult time but having that I he was
able to you know surpass that go to
medical school in India and then she
comes to us do residency and now
michelle has a full-time you know
critical care doctor and he's been able
to provide so much for his family and
even his extended family so since he had
that experience
he was then you know impressing that
upon us and because he impressed that
upon us we have you know it really just
sparked why I wanted to make this
organization a continuous charity it was
the the lessons from my father and on
top of that it was just what we see in
society like you said like we see I used
to do a lot of youth groups in San Diego
we had a lot of small and refugees a lot
of Afghan refugees and you know they had
no guidance they didn't know what to do
how to go to school they were kind of
doing dead-end jobs but they're so
educated in the sense of like they were
a very intelligent when I might say
they're very intelligent hard-working
dedicated even more so than myself so it
really inspired myself and my team to
you know to make this organization and
to make it a reality for other people to
get higher education without having to
get into interspace debt so your father
I mean so he helped you now that's
interesting you said studying under the
lights streetlights yeah I mean this
apana in India
at that time he actually his father had
passed away when he was younger so is
this
he had Tim and he had like six brothers
and sisters so the brothers had to work
and they would always try to get him to
work because he's like hey you need to
support the family your mom's at home we
don't have that much food but he's like
no I have a vision that education will
bring us out of this darkness that's out
of this poverty and they were they were
working in our there by Singh Dhillon
newspapers delivering food whatever it
might be but he's like no you guys I'm
gonna study and I promise you this will
have paid dividends in the future
and subhanAllah after even though it
took 20 or 30 years and now all my
entire family's living here in the u.s.
they all have migrated here and having
been living better prosperous lives not
only just from financially but even for
Islamic Li as well so he what he was 100
Center I that education can change the
trajectory of your family in a giant I
pointed out so how did how did they get
around this again the falling into this
deep debt um well I mean my so my father
my father oh yes so the way that at
least the way that I avoided it which is
he I forgot that was the initial
question that yeah so my father being a
physician wanted me to also become a
physician and I was telling him listen
you know III it's okay for me to become
a physician but I'm not gonna go into
interest-based it just to you know
satisfy so i told me if you want me to
become a doctor you're gonna have to pay
for it and then he was like i really
wants to become a doctor so so he ended
up paying for it and i think that's a
nice from you also to start the
organization because for me allah had
blessed I had obviously I had no
decision on who my parents are gonna be
right but Allah put me and chose me in a
particular situation where my father's
doctor and my mom's also doctor as well
so they will to financially support all
of their children and send them to
medical school without falling in that
in RIBA usury interest trap exactly yes
the pala so it was a really big huge
blessing and so I felt like you know
there are people out there that are
smarter than me that are more dedicated
than me that have so much more desire to
help themselves help their family so I'm
like whoa Allah put me in a situation
where I don't have to go through that
but it wasn't anything that I did myself
so let me try to bring that to other
people as much as I can and that's kind
of what our team what our goal was for
the team that were created and if I'm
doula now or six years later I'm that
we're trying to do our best to you know
alleviate this stress from other people
I mean it doesn't stop there and and
this is good that people anybody
I want anybody who is considering
getting a student loan somebody who is
in the state of Higher Education now and
they have to consider that they God will
and they can watch this episode and now
really get to ponder and think some more
because we're bringing some very valid
crucial points the next thing that is
linked to this debt is suicide
depression what are the you talked about
some of the numbers there that you have
the direct result of this is now what
happens from their suicide depression
exactly yeah these things so there's a
lot of research that are not only our
team is doing but obviously bigger
organizations have done in the last 20
or 30 years and shown that debt in
general so we were saying that mortgage
debt being number one then student loans
and then I think credit cards and then
cars in general are the biggest debt in
the u.s. so just being in debt in
general like and you'll see on this
video that it not only affects your
health but it affects your mental health
so we have seen an increase in
depression we've seen an increase in
suicide even in Chicago I think within
the last six months there was actually a
person who specifically committed
suicide because of the debt there that
they were that they were suffering from
being from going to school I mean it and
it's a staggering number I mean just I
mean one death enough from suicide from
a financial reason I mean is such a
significant to such an impactful thing
and and we think as Muslims sometimes we
live in a bubble but unfortunately this
bubbles has been popped a long time ago
so that same effect that normal some
Americans see most of Americans are
seeing then as well so we're definitely
being affected by this financial burden
called interest or interest based debt
because of student loans when you go
deep into this you see that this is just
another point of reference pointing to
that indeed Islam does Dean is from the
Creator that this is another proof
someone says how was that Eddie because
why would this man Prophet Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him not only
brought you know on his expounding
character you know pristine character a
believable message connecting with all
the other messengers they brought the
same message the worship of the Creator
not to creation pure monotheism but now
at the same time he's bringing
the Quran the ultimate proof but in
there why would he if he wants to gain
followers he's gonna prohibit alcohol
he's gonna prohibit fornication he's
gonna you know prohibit these things in
life that people gravitate towards they
want to enjoy and now and on top of that
interest why would he do that
right exactly it doesn't make sense true
I mean it's a pretty except proofing
itself this is a complete message it
comes from the Creator who knows us in
and out what's good for us what's bad
for us not only just from like I said
for Speros perspective but in all realms
of our life yeah including finances it
doesn't make sense now you know fasting
30 you know where we're at right now and
Ramadan but for each one of these if you
look at porn if you look at from pork
tell us something for them from a
medical perspective I mean these are the
things that at that time when it was
prohibitive we didn't have scientific
facts now of the health you know you get
one of these worms in your brain it's
great especially now with first leap
agony we didn't have ass like maybe
sanitary conditions and they were
cooking the meat as much and you don't
have like this the idea of microbiology
and things of that nature yeah for sure
I was reading an article on CNN it's
like you know you take even many
Christians are coming out and speaking
against and I'm gonna correlate this
with what we're talking about here the
interest specifically but with pork you
we posted an article and I don't know
how any one it was from a Christian
that's actually from dr. axe have you
he's one of the leading nutritionists in
the States
he's a Christian and and he gives all
the common arguments as someone might
have on why they might eat pork was the
main thing is the the if you if it's
undercooked then you the chances are so
high of having a health disaster but you
know he even addresses that okay so
that's one thing the alcohol the World
Health Organization estimates that every
10 seconds someone is dying from this
drug alcohol so again now we start to
see things unfolding of the love that a
law has towards us so why certain things
are prohibited fasting look all the
health benefits I'm sure now you know as
a medical down it's many are even
there's new research now of it fighting
cancer and we're talking about
the harm of interests yeah protecting
humanity exactly as I made it I'm
beautiful religion duh I was perfect on
all aspects of Hollow
so how do people now get involved so
this is your offering a alternative so
we we take away you'll take away the
alcohol and you give them all these
beautiful smoothies and you give them
all of these nutritional drinks right
yeah you take away the the pig and you
have all these different beautiful meats
you got lamb you got beef you got you
know sushi got all this stuff you know
yeah now you take away this interest
what are you giving them it's a good
point so so we are basically offering
interest-free loans for higher education
and so far like I feel this organization
it's almost like a David and Goliath
type situation we have this Goliath of
interest rates loans that you can get it
anywhere it's everywhere it's a freely
available you can get at any age you
want to it's almost like you said like
alcoholic drugs you know it's very very
easily accessible and this other
alternative we're trying to change the
system you know we're trying to be that
underdog that's trying to then overcome
this huge ah specifically at slang in
front of us and as an organization I'm
gonna even though we we've given like I
said 1.5 million dollars in
interest-free loans and while that seems
like 1.5 trillion you know it's the less
than a percent of the of the whole pool
of interest based unfortunately but
we're trying to work together slowly to
amount a big response or a huge response
against this entire system so that what
we're offering these people is better
not only just interest-free loans
because that's one thing but we're
offering education how to go to school
we're offering by taking an
interest-free loan you're going to
negate all of those negative stigma that
comes with interspace that that every
time you pay this monthly payment like
me like you'll see they don't ninety
percent of it will go to the interest
spring interest rate you won't be able
to you'll be able to give me have your
payments on time you won't have that
mental stress I mean there's so many
benefits to like I said following the
religion of the one creator god I lost
panel Donna by taking an interest free
day I've seen I mean I've seen people
try to collect money to pay off
somebody's loan I know a medical doctor
medical doctors who have completed a
school and then I've seen some of these
statements that they have of debt I
believe it was almost four hundred how
do you get almost four hundred thousand
dollars you are in Slate and you still
you're still trying the person still
cannot get a job oh they're still trying
to they finish you know the residency
but it's not just like okay you're
guaranteed you're gonna get in and now
this debt is still coming in and you're
not paying it and now it's compounding
is coming on and it's you're just
digging a deeper hole a deeper hole and
now you just end up now you get the job
and you're working like it's no easy job
in the dark yeah it's not work I mean
they work you like a slave in and of
itself that's true that's true you get
it from one way then you get it from the
other now you've got this this debt and
what if you die on them yeah guaranteed
that you're gonna now you gotta you're
working and finally let's say you pay it
off you pay it off you finally pay it
off and you and now your health goes bad
yeah not all that money's coming in
right that you finally are starting to
make some money and now you got to go
pay pay off you know to try to regain
that health that was caused by this
stress of this interest-based law or
maybe the worst case now you die in that
state is it yeah that's a lot yeah and
one of the things I think people and
it's hard to really I guess see the
benefit of blessings or Baraka or what
we call in English blessings of your
wealth one of the things that God does
is when you get your wealth from a
sacred source if you get it from an a
halal or acceptable means that there's
an added element of butter korre
blessing that comes with your money and
it's that's something you can't really
rate on the scale something you can't
really count but in essence if you get
your wealth or education is based off
interest based loans where where that is
going against the Word of God that it
will then suck out all of that blessing
and extra butter cuz that you have in
your wealth and like you said you'll
have this stress you'll have you'll be
fine you might be making a bunch of
money but where's all that money going
you might not only just be going to the
debt but you might be losing this your
car might break down your house might be
on fire I mean it's it's amazing what
can happen and the stories that we've
heard of people who have been like you
said debt-free interest-free I mean the
the extent that their dollar can go is
like you know they'll spend it all it
would be like ten or fifteen dollars
just because God will put blessing into
their wealth because he'd they chose not
to disobey the words of God that's deep
right there what motivated you what got
you to a point I mean really that you
stood up and you told your parents
that look if you want me to go you got
to pay for this I mean you obviously
what you are committed to your Deen what
got you to that stake you know I mean
there's not a single thing that I did to
deserve what in the situation I might
now Allah has really blessed me and
guided me to the path and Sean Miller
continued got all of us through the
straight path but you know just I think
when I was younger in college you know
we had like an MSA and then you they
were influenced I felt like influencing
that right in the right direction and we
definitely sin to some lecturers and and
you know it's just really truly I mean
there's nothing really I can pinpoint
whether than just a blessing of Allah he
chose to put me on this path and
inshallah I'll be able to preserve this
path and continue to move in what was it
about Islam obviously like you know you
get to go into school now you get to
study and you can you know tested you
know people usually you go in that
academic setting it's China the Dow is
to pull you away from a crater from a
Dean from this system right I you don't
say religion because Islam is more than
that that's what's complete way of life
I'm sure you were tested you went to you
know many tests what care and many do go
through these tests and they fail right
they drop off you know they leave but
what kept you committed to this Deen you
mentioned this but what were some of
them because we know this Deen Islam is
based on proof it's proof and evidence
it's not just blind commitment right so
what was it what were some of the things
that you look back at and you saw that
it confirmed you making a conscious
decision that Islam is deep indeed from
the Creator you know it's a good
question and I come from a family who
you know we're Muslim by birth but maybe
not the most practicing Muslims you know
we we definitely pray and fasten on hold
on but outside of Ramadan maybe you
might confuse this with just that the
average American right so I think when I
was 19 actually I specifically remember
I was down on myself I was in a
situation where I really had to choose
which direction I wanted to head you
know and I really I felt like I really
turned to a lot and made a conscious
decision of like hey you know I was born
a Muslim and maybe I was born Muslim for
a reason and I really got to you know
stick with my principles and I think
when I was 19 I I specifically was like
I was in summer school as a UCLA and I
was a little bit living by myself it was
really really I was really in a tough
place you know like no one really wants
to be themselves eating by themselves
and I was doing things by themselves and
it really was a time for a personal
reflection and I think based off of the
decision
that I made at that time I really felt
that Allah had opened up the doors for
me and you know when the Euro 2000 opens
up a door free and you take it he'll
open up another door of good and just
like just equivalent just if I'll opens
up a door of bad and you take that or
bad there might be another thousand
doors that that he could open up for you
potentially so I felt like since I try I
chose to follow the path of Allah the
path of the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him that Allah continued to open
doors of good and this is just one of
those that I felt that I could give back
to the community and so I'm this this
path after certains organization has
been a really truly blessed and even
though we've you know if you've met
obstacles with myself and my team know I
have a home that I great team I felt
like we were able to overcome those
obstacles and you know continue to push
forward you know the worst things that
I'm not the worst things but a sad thing
when I go and I see a group of doctors
and they're drinking coca-cola and
they're eating all these you know fake
foods definitely just a lot of for me
yeah but how the reason I bring this up
is because I heard also that you you
also you're into nutrition you also
train Gracie jiu-jitsu yeah I felt like
I mean it's amazing that I think a lot
of us we like to invest into like you
know offense like a great car and great
house but just I think the importance of
what you're putting inside of your own
body is equally and ever more importance
so definitely I think nutrition is a
huge factor in staying healthy and
living like an Islamic life so I think
it's part of what the prophets all are
some were to want us to do is eat
healthy eat right correct and I think
definite like you know these fake foods
like you said coke and all this fast
food places I mean it's I mean it's
really like destroying our health and
you can see that the epic am an epidemic
of like diabetes and just bad health
increasing the rates of cancer even
amongst the young I mean and things that
we see in the hospital it's amazing and
you were mentioning about alcohol being
a drug I mean there's so many people
that I see in the hospital that have
just end organ damage from alcohol yeah
so like whether it's their kidneys
whether it's their liver whether it's a
long haul from alkyl specifically from
agra it's it's amazing i once they get
to a certain level of like for instance
it's called cirrhosis like death of the
liver almost i mean these people are in
and out of the hospital and we oh you
know the the wind can blow the wrong way
and they can end up in
you know it's it's such a sad situation
but I think this goes back to the point
of this Dean being a complete way of
life and a lot in the profits along I
sell a lot of some peace be upon him are
wanting us to you know part of that is
this nutrition eating correctly and
staying healthy and your life and that
includes I exercise and doing jiu-jitsu
soccer or whatever it might be but just
like keeping active keeping healthy yeah
that's deep why do you think that
doctors in medical school they don't
learn about nutrition you have to go
outside it most likely right yeah that's
you so yeah that's good so I feel like
unfortunately there's like there is like
a general tract of knowledge that people
want you to follow and I think it's all
comes back to money because eventually
like this allopathic school of medicine
is going to you're going to be
reimbursed for the evidence-based
guidelines that you follow these
protocols that you follow and because of
that if you were to mean outside and
something were to happen you might be
able you actually might get in trouble
might lose your license because like hey
this is what everybody's doing and your
peers are doing this and now you've done
that and not like look this about
outcome happy even though if you do this
a lot about outcomes outcomes happen as
well but but just because everybody's
doing that it makes it easier to you
know approval everybody else to do it
and it's just part of it it's just a
regular complication but if you were to
do something outside of that you know it
could become you know you can lose your
medical license for instance because a
lot of people are obviously not going to
do that because they work so hard to get
their license in this place I've heard
from from many experts in the field that
you know you have a lot of
evidence-based science behind many
things but it doesn't it takes years
almost like 17 years where it trickles
down into the conventional system like
you have so much research now on being
done proven scientific research on what
we're doing today on fasting but you
don't have you don't see any doctors you
come to a hospital you tell me go fast
but there's science behind it oh for
sure yeah 100% I think unfortunately
like the way that the US at least a
Western medical society is is that we
want to treat everything with a pill and
don't get me wrong that there is
definitely a financial benefit pharmacy
companies I like they don't want to
study this puts too much money into
benefits of faster eating correctly
because they know the American people
would like to eat what they want to do
what they want to take a pill and then
that they'll benefit from that American
people will get some you know some
the quick satisfaction that they can get
from eating whatever they want so it's
really it's a really sad circle
unfortunately but that's kind of the
system that we're in and and living in
the 21st century I mean it's it's hard
to break that cycle move outward without
having like to say facing some other two
other difficulties I can go on and on
there it's a whole different topic but
this is important I mean like you know
Hippocrates I said let food be your
medicine and medicine be your food
because doctors take that Hippocratic
oath right yes and he was like the
father of medicine Yeah right this is
and this goes in line with the Sunnah
this goes in way you know we're a lost
month all of the crater is telling us
there's one thing between eating halal
but people have gone away they don't
even reflect both tell you bad
yeah they got Almighty Allah saying eat
of to tell you about the good food and
the good food is not the fake food so
and then and then also tell my exercise
doing some Shih Tzu sports you know and
then but now really as a student stress
eliminating stress and you're not going
to eliminate stress if you have enslaved
yourself to this debt exactly I mean the
only way to ill me all types of stress
in life is to inflate yourself to Allah
and to follow his rules and his
regulations and by taking interest space
there especially in it and I'm not
blaming anybody because really it's it's
not an individual fall it's a societal
level like as a Muslim community and as
an American community we have to
understand that these students are not
just educating themselves so they could
become rich in the future but they're
educating themselves so they can help
their children and their families for
generations to come
and the society in themselves I'm how
many people benefit has our American
society seen just from the benefits of
people going to school and then finding
the new novel and innovations and and
making things better than they were in
the past and unfortunately we've gone to
the point where word then crippling them
with this debt and that prevents so many
people from then you know going out like
to say they have a certain job well they
have to work extra at the jobless they
can pay their debt up and pay their
bills and they're not able to go out and
volunteer you know they're not able to
go to help build someone's house rebuild
someone's house or do community service
work it becomes very difficult very
stressful and so unfortunately we're in
the system and our organization a
continuous charity is trying to revamp
that and to make a difference in
people's lives by providing giving them
the ability to live a life of you know
of interest an interest free life and
that's really what
our goal is as a religion is to really
live like an inches free life at least
from a financial perspective and I'm
that we've seen a lot of benefit from
our receive I like you will end with
that enslave yourself to the the one who
created you to the Creator God Almighty
Allah and then you live by the guidance
and you have that's how you have trust
trust and you obey and now knowing that
anything that's harmful for us it's been
prohibited for a reason is there any
good books or anything else there's some
one kid now because a lot of times
things someone can be really you know
academically savvy and they're smart but
a lot of times when you don't go down
these rabbit holes you don't look into
this specific thing you know a lot of
this is now new for someone and is there
direction you can point them and they
can they can look further into this
because you have a lot of not yet
Muslims non-muslims out there who who
are who you know there's a really great
interview by it's called a book called
the confessions of a economic hitman
this is one is there anything else that
you that you recommend someone read or
to get more educated in this area and
interest yeah definitely question so I
think on our website actually we have
different resources for people yeah so
if you go to ACC educate org so again
ACC educate org you can find a list of
resources not only just about reading
about these kind of things but
specifically about education and even
going to scholarships and other
interest-free loans and I mean there's a
lot of different things that we can
offer just from our website and if you
obviously be contact us through the
website as well we can also provide
different information as well we
actually have a launch good campaign as
well this this year so launched good.com
it's the last interest-free you can also
learn about more about our organization
at that website and you don't get more
resources as well to hopefully then take
yourself out of this interest-based life
into an interest-free life therefore you
know submitting yourself to the one and
only creator thank you and thank you
guys for tuning in and it's in your
interest to go ahead and not just attach
yourself to something as temporary but
something that's permanent and that's
Jenna and you have the guidance here and
we touched upon some of the wisdoms and
from there in sha allah you can go ahead
and leave some of your takeaways in the
comments below subscribe to get more of
our programs sent to you and she'll log
on Wilin you have a blessed Ramadan and
we'll see you next time tune in every
week
here at the Dean show until then peace
be with you as Salaam aleikum